tras horas de pie y pasar la noche a la
intemperie Los Seguidores de la reina
que enfrentan colas kilométricas para
ver su féretro recibieron una visita
inesperada la del Rey Carlos III que
estrechó las manos e intercambió algunas
palabras con el público y la del
príncipe William ahora heredero al Trono
de Reino Unido
Y es que ver a la reina por última vez
ha sido todo un reto después de que el
tiempo de la fila para llegar hasta el
féretro expuesto a un Westminster Hall
llegar a superar las 24 horas allí más
de 430 personas han necesitado atención
médica por desmayos y Golpes en la
cabeza en la cola según el servicio de
ambulancias de Londres no obstante
muchos piensan que la ocasión merece la
pena y con la visita del Rey aún más
fue una experiencia increíble conocer al
Rey Carlos III y le dije a Su Majestad
que siguiera con su increíble trabajo y
él respondió tendré que hacerlo porque
ahora tengo que cuidar de ustedes
tras varias jornadas de filas
kilométricas ahora a dos días del
funeral de la reina los que todavía no
lo han conseguido conservan la esperanza
de llegar a tiempo para despedirse el
lunes se espera que cerca de 100
presidentes y jefes de estado acudan al
funeral de estado en lo que se espera
como uno de los mayores eventos de la
historia de Reino Unido